[Music]
who knows how things are going to turn
out on Dancing with the Stars of course
but I did learn this normanni and vow
they'll be kicking it Monday night
Disney night and we do Milan move on
okay there's a lot of karate for the
first time since the season started
valid normani are rehearsing in LA all
week instead of squeezing it in while on
the road with norm on ease girl group
fifth harmony they hit eight countries
in less than a month alright just landed
in the philippines manila finally over
playing sixteen hours later she's still
gonna record with fifth harmony but at
least we want to fly for twenty hours a
week do you think that the judges will
be raising their expectations because
they know that you are now in town and
you've got all this time they probably
will yeah they probably will bring back
in LA also allows Val to spend some time
with brother Max and Peter's little
bundle of joy baby shot uncle duties
have been awesome when I have a chance
to hang out with him um always at the
house and he's always smiling back so we
already you know it's a beautiful thing
it can be so cute even women will swoon
the ones that aren't swooning already
with your shirt unbuttoned to your belly
button
yeah I'm saying I want everybody at home
to know this happens not only on the
live show this happens at rehearsal to
the whole lot good keeping the buttons
undone I was gonna show up wait what's
happening done
ah what about his room please come on
Omar's to Val huh
[Music]
you